the following contains Oilers for the
upcoming season of Game of Thrones hey
guys today I'm going to talk about jon
snow's fate in season 7 I'm going to
explain every band related to Jon
in this video you're going to see John
in Winterfell in Dragonstone any his bad
will be on the wall based on leaked
photos click plot and our theories as
well so let's just jump into it as you
already probably know HBO Realty is
revenue season a week ago which only few
lucky fans could see just before the new
episode of West rolled meanwhile this
video has been uploaded online on HBO
special YouTube channel a few days ago
however in that age be a short video we
can see John talking to someone probably
to Sansa in our opinion that's a scene
in which John is saying to censor that
he has received an invitation from
Daenerys to come and meet her at
Dragonstone and that is heading south
according to Lee plot Hill said sense as
the rule of Winterfell while John's
being a Dragonstone this scene is
obviously happening before John's rival
chores of Dragonstone as we can see from
leaked photos Kit Harington known as Jon
Snow was on filming set on Isle at
Gaston lights in Basque Country the
location which will represent
Dragonstone in the upcoming season also
we can see the scene which tyrion
Missoni and cano welcome Jon Snow and
that was to Dragonstone with formal
handshake between the king in the north
and the hand of the Queen later from
leaked photos we can see Jon Snow and I
was walking on the walls of Dragonstone
and talking while few Dothraki warriors
are guarding them after John and I was
to arrive at Dragonstone it won't take
too long to wait for a meeting between
John and Daenerys here is the proof the
image was taken from a distance but it's
without adopt an official meeting
between the nearest Rogerian and Jon
Snow as the reason of their meeting we
can assume it's Daenerys who set an
annotation to demand from John to
support her as rightful claim ER or the
Iron Throne while John accepts an
invitation to come with Dragonstone
discuss with the nurse about rewarded
scamming and to try to convince her that
real wars just about the camp it's the
one against the night's king's army at
first the nearest one blade to john
material convinced her that she has to
give me a chance to prove his statements
while John's presence at Dragonstone
there will also be a meeting between him
and team Greyjoy it was alfie allen's
or
aka teens first appearance on set this
year and he had it didn't start well for
TN we had seen the scene in with John
Davos Missoni and a few Dothraki
warriors welcome to just arriving on and
few Ironborn man in the shores of
Dragonstone actually the word welcome is
not the most appropriate term for that
team as well expected John is furious
while meeting Theon that man who
betrayed his brother actually his cousin
Robb Stark took the Winterfell by force
including killing few loyal Starks man
firstly went in right Dragonstone John
grabbed him by the labels well he can
hear what he is saying to him we can
assume he's probably insulting him
fortunately 14 the king in North
abstained himself instead of escalating
the conflict jock had gone off in an
anger we've explained where from team
came and what's the meaning of the iron
burns beating Theon after Jones finished
with him in one of our previous videos
meanwhile Jorah Mormont also came to
Dragonstone while the crew was filming
Zumaya
George seen talking to Tyrion as
Daenerys approached escorted by the
trakis as her guard and had a
conversation Jorah irrelevant to this
topic but we noticed that we had to
highlight that Daenerys is wearing black
outfit with a red cloak which means the
Daenerys will finally wear colors of her
house in the upcoming season however the
main question is the joerger his
grayscale or did he fail his mission but
has returned to Danny anyway to help her
as long as he can before it spreads that
much until it makes him kill himself now
have to wait a little longer not the
answer on that question also there's one
more major role that is going to appear
in season 7 at Dragonstone and meet with
all these main characters it's January
Joe Dempsey the actor that plays January
appeared on filming set on mural beach
in Baraka the leaked photo shows the
dials and January probably at King's
Landing and were together preparing the
boat leave when all the sudden two gold
cloaks approached Davos then favorite of
all the conflict demonstrated to Dan
that the boat is instantly empty by
pulling the back to tarp that was also
bright the gold cloaks
who turned to leave but just then Tyrion
showed up and passed by them the gold
cloaks have spotted a Tyrion and came
back immediately
perhaps they recognized him or suspected
that
maybe Tyrion Lannister that was try to
go into a possible conflict by trying to
talk to them by the guards grab their
swords
that's when gently reacted picked up his
Warhammer from the boat and struck him
from behind then diverse students in
January pushed the boat offshore and
headed to Dragonstone now when the most
main characters are in Dragonstone
for instance Daenerys since Annie where
is Tyrion great warm Jon Snow Davos
team Greyjoy Gendry and Jorah next what
we going to see is a few of them
preparing to leave from link photos we
can see during the near stalking scene
in which Danny says farewell to her
advisor who in return miles to his
screen as the scene goes on the nearest
turns to Jon meanwhile Jorah helps some
men to prepare the boat these men as you
can see in the photos are Davos in
January as if told jenny was brought to
Dragonstone the scene doesn't
surprisingly as John doubles Gendry and
Jorah push the boat and go away together
what everyone won't know now is where
are they going our first thought is
north be on the ball as league plots as
John Bailey Jorah Davos in January to
get rid hunt two brothers without
banners
Tommen and a few brothers from Night
Watch are going to try to catch white in
favour to prove the nearest and show the
rest of the Empire the real danger that
threatens them their son let's called
proofs they're going in favor for this
theory Game of Thrones crew have been
quietly constructing a large snow is
said that woke Hill curry in the hills
above balfus group has blanketed the
area with fake snow and created an
artificial ice surface rather like an
iced over Lake you can also see a large
green screen with snowing ground beneath
it a nice location points to season 7
taking us beyond the wall in kind of
sports our theory as if set our thoughts
are that they are going beyond the wall
which fit the ice location that the crew
is trying to make as best as they can
also in league plot nerds mention that
John and his team will get a tag by an
ice king's army while they are trying to
catch white in details they were
described that they are going to be
attacked on the ice surface by undead
army and white polar bear in which one
brother without banners is going to get
killed
apparently the most John's team actually
all of them will be saved by Daenerys
and her dragons while she will manage to
save John John will almost get
while being surrounded by the hoard of
white walkers and whites and all the
sudden benjin will appear and save his
nephew
it seems that benjin's role in Game of
Thrones is to save his nephews as we
know benjin has already said bran in
case you forgot by the league plot
Benjamin said Boone and John on his
horse and save him while he'll stay and
fight as long as he can and I stole a
snowy ground with fake snow and the ice
surface that the crew made seems that
the morning pits only plot furthermore
there are some hard proofs as we have
two league photos the first one we can
see the unity White Walkers in this crew
mates at which they were preparing for a
few weeks for this shooting 300 stars
had been brought in this Isis set what
make this theory almost hundred percent
true second photo also goes in favour to
this theory as we can see three
characters that have never crossed paths
in previous season but are now together
just like your sets and guess where they
are all at belfast the location where
the crew was preparing an Isis set for a
few weeks third photo would be a final
confirmation for this theory by this
leaked photos quality's way too low in
our opinion it's John preparing for
filming on the ISIS ad but since the
quality is to allow we're going to wait
a little more to proclaim this theory as
confirmed but be sure that we are going
to give even more proofs about this
theory after Denair save John's rube
from the undead horde
she will obviously this point bolita
John statements about White Walkers and
whites John and Daenerys fell at this
point need other Lord support they need
all men who can swing with sward they
need all the armies to have a chance
against Knight king's army but for all
the other lords they need to have the
proves to gain their support there are
some rumors only plot eventually John
will somehow catch white with the nurses
help after his first failed attempt
which could be an explanation of most
excited scene is going to happen in
season 7 it was seen from filming in
sounder Spain the scene from Metallica
set italic assembly theatre and Seville
soil shipyards will depict the dragon
pit Jeremy Podesta the guy who is
directing season 7 premiere in the
finale was in in telecom which surely
plays the scene in season 7 finale
rather than season 7 premiere this is
even more exciting once you realize that
13 starring cast
members are confirmed to have a role at
the dragon pit accompanied by four guest
stars with 17 major characters the same
film the dragon pit will be most
important scene in season 7 for future
events this is a historic confluence of
characters Circe Daenerys Jon Snow
Tyrion Jaime Dallas sandy sander Thien
Brienne Boris Bronn Jorah urine Qyburn
Pat and Gregor but all these characters
being together at the same place
anything is possible to happen the
question is while all of them together
at the same place and dragon pit in our
opinion all the Lords of Westeros and
all important powerful people will be
invited as dragon pit by Jon Snow or
Daenerys Targaryen to witness the true
danger that faces them the danger White
Walkers horde and horde of their whites
while bigger part of the lords are going
to be horrified by seeing the white and
will agree to unite all of their armed
together as one in favour to have a
chance of surviving according to plot
league search is going to be skeptical
she won't consider it as a true danger
and the Lord heard the mountain to kill
the white and prove to everyone that
it's not a big deal blood League says
that mountain will fail to accomplish
the order he won't killed white but even
after the white gets to the final point
of dismemberment while it seems that old
Lord supported Jon Snow in the nearest
they're going to send her arms to North
Cersei doesn't considered situation as
everyone else does furthermore search
welcomes the Horde White Walkers
alongside with their whites she
considers the Horde abandoned army will
only benefit her by killing all of her
enemies the lasting old fans are
wondering about is will Brown revealed
to jock who his real mother is the
answer is simply no bran will arrive in
Winterfell in the first few episodes of
the upcoming season but not soon enough
bran will arrive in middle file while
John's already at Dragonstone
or is heading to Dragonstone this is our
opinion about Jon Snow's fate in season
7 supported by leaked photos and leaf
plot thank you for watching and if you
join this video please make sure you
subscribe to our Channel
two minutes
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]